okay Michael how do I persuade a
developer to code for me even though I
do not have much money since I'm a
student with a lot of student
entrepreneurs here I love that no I'm
and a couple of gigs we started we got
people actually one of the companies i
went to another style of california
startup this is a long time ago about 18
years ago we kind of work for nothing
for a while did run ourselves on fumes
but boy it makes you really hustle but
we we got basically I one of the guys
when we took a mom we said with Trey
kind of cash for equity and we gave Miss
very small percentage in terms of the
company so there's loads of things you
can do and again I think if you're right
at the start of a product with these
lilies you've got to avoid boiling the
ocean you just gotta start small and
then when you got something works scale
it up so so my question for you if
you're going to code a product and
you're going to build some technology
build an app whatever it might be kind
of what's the minimum viable product
that you need to build and these days
with technology hopefully build that in
less than a couple of weeks but I reckon
for a couple of weeks coding someone's
likely to work for free and there's
loads of things you can do you can do
the third earnings you know and you
could say lock it to the company's
success you could give them a small
portion of equity says loads of creative
things you can do but also you know
obviously if you give people money
ironic and this is sad about human
nature they tend to switch off from the
mission if you actually say you know if
we land on the moon together we take
some moon shots and everybody's kind of
got skin in the game it really drives a
great culture and it keeps some keen as
mustard to really bit on the company
success and also the only other thing of
college students I know you know if you
build an app you reckon you can build it
out of it three days it always takes a
bit longer than you think so what you
need to do is keep keep that I'm solar
student really focused on delivering the
Minimum Viable Product and getting
something that hands of customers so
they can road test it
and then you'll validate whether you got
a business and then then you can share
it but I think they finally out says
we'll all these things just got to be
honest with because this guy could be a
potential coworker if he does a great
job code in your app do you want it to
be your first employee so how do you
think about him being you know
effectively a co-founder of the company
and being on the management team maybe
it's not the guy may be easily best
techie and he's coding for you so you
need to kind of think of it head of how
the movie might play out but I also
think you owe it to that individual to
share with them and be honest with them
and transparent with them you haven't
got you know you're not kind of Warren
Buffett yeah you're a student you've got
a dream you you wanted to be part of it
selling the story if he believes in the
story he'll cut that LLL cut code for
you yeah I mean the only thing I agree
with everything Steven saying the only
thing I would add is if you want to be a
tech company you need to have tech
leadership in your team you can't be a
successful app company like if you're so
you're not a coder you want to run a nap
great you can't just have somebody who
you hire and then you know does
occasional maintenance on it if you want
to be a successful app company you need
to have somebody who cares just as
deeply as you do about the business and
as part of the company so you need a
co-founder and that's not a decision
that you just take lightly you don't
just enter into business with somebody
and like the values are super important
to not just a skill set but I wouldn't
if you treat this just as I can hire
somebody and you know when I need them
on I'll bring them on that is not the
way to build a successful tech company
if you don't know how to do the tech
yourself you need somebody who's just as
committed to doing this and build that
company if you do the business item they
do the tack but if you want to make it
big you got like look at every
successful tech company one of the
co-founders knew the tech you need
somebody on your on your team who's
deeply committed who understands attack